for months now the parents movement has
gained steam all around america storming
school board meetings exposing radical
teachers even deciding the virginia
gubernatorial election
but just as these normal moms and dads
think that they are hitting their stride
the peak of their powers
one teacher has taken to tick-tock to
give everyone a reality check
so i see how you think that you've done
something here because
parents or community members have voiced
concern
to their elected official which is how
the process works
um
not not bringing it to a teacher right
they're taking it to the elected
official
and now that uh legislators are are
trying to implement these things um but
still in fact a parent
not my boss
i don't i don't actually
answer to them so
get bent
so get bent so
arrogant
so
radical
so
obviously correct
yes we can complain to our
representatives about radical racial and
sexual ideologies in the classroom yes
we can go viral at school board meetings
and even win some of those seats for
ourselves yes
we can even occasionally get a
particularly insane educator put on i
don't know administrative leave
but the radicals still run the schools
they still run the classrooms and the
administrations and the teacher unions
and the training sessions and the
curricula and just about everything else
in the education system
they've got
real power and they intend to hold on to
that power no matter what we do at the
school board meetings or at the ballot
box
these radicals who are raising our kids
don't think parents are their bosses
because right now at least
we're not i'm michael knowles that's the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from facto who says
in the immortal words of maury povich
pierre you are not the father
i think you're referring to pierre
trudeau the alleged father of canadian
prime minister justin trudeau who bears
a very strange resemblance to a a
certain
latin american island dictator uh
communist by the name of fidel castro
who had a very close relationship to the
trudeau's and to justin trudeau's mother
right around the time that justin
trudeau was conceived i don't know i
don't know i do in the words of
telemachus it's a wise man who knows his
own father it's it's unclear uh justin
surely exhibits some of the features of
mr castro but pierre trudeau was no walk
in the park either uh there i think
they're all probably cut from the same
cloth who knows who knows it's a wise
man who knows his own father it's you've
got you got to make sure that you ground
your identity in something real and you
protect your identity when you want to
protect your identity i would recommend
you check out lifelock keeping your
internet connected devices up to date is
always a good idea not just for
consumers but for companies as well
because when you don't keep them up to
date sometimes cyber criminals can take
advantage there's one bug that's getting
a ton of media attention right now it's
called log four j
log 4j cyber criminals can exploit this
bug to break into a server and steal
data
every single day we put our information
at risk on the internet in an instant a
cyber criminal could steal what is yours
sometimes even harm your finances your
credit your good reputation thank
goodness
there's lifelock go check out lifelock
today it helps detect a wide range of
identity threats such as your social
security number for sale on the dark web
if they detect your information has
potentially been compromised they'll
send you an alert they've got a
dedicated restoration specialist if you
become a victim no one can prevent all
identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses but you
can help protect what's yours with
lifelock by norton head on over right
now get 25
off your first year at lifelock.com
slash knowles that's up to 25 off your
first year lifelock.com
knowles
this teacher who just went viral
the one who says get bent parents you're
not my boss
she is not the only teacher who is
threatening people who is threatening
parents students society at large
there's another teacher who just went
viral this from our friends over at libs
of tick tock
a teacher a black teacher
who is threatening
white people on purely on the basis of
racial animus
black people black people colors only i
got a question so you understand it in
public right you stand in public and you
see white people do you ever get the
urge to just
you know
you know like you're minding your
business like they're kind of minding
their business and you just
just scared someone
just disappeared just stare a little bit
just to scare them a little bit just to
give them the feeling like today's the
day today's the day
that black people start retaliating just
to give them a little bit of it the
burning feeling inside
no just me
oh let me know
today's the day today is that okay now
i'm gonna go teach your kids your kids
of all different races even the ones
that i hate
even even the students
whom i hate on the basis of their race
because of my ideology that says that
all white people are oppressors and all
black people are oppressed and it it's
an ideology that comes straight out of
marxism the sort of later stages of 20th
century marxism yeah i'm going to be the
ones teaching your kids isn't that a
good idea
my issue here
is not
that the teacher is making a joke i hope
it's a joke my issue here is not even
that the teacher is making a racial joke
i think racial jokes are fine i think
jokes about ethnicities and cultures and
yes even races if they're made in good
faith and good fun are totally fine
my issue here is that the teacher is
making comments
that are clearly not in good fun clearly
not in good faith and that the teacher
has a very perverse ideology that is
going to destroy the education of her
students and so she should not be
allowed to teach the kids she should be
fired simple as that okay that's how
we're going to wield power
the way we're going to wield power is if
yes we go to the school boards yes we
complain yes we go elect people but
you've you've got to get into the
classrooms okay you've got
it goes without saying i don't even want
to say it
it's so lame
every time a conservative but you know
what is the conservative they say well
imagine imagine if the roles were
reversed imagine if the shoe were on the
other foot and you had a teacher let's
say you had a i don't know a hispanic
teacher walking in and saying hey
whenever you see black people don't you
just want to threaten them don't you
just want a guy and say today's the day
well of course that's that's not that's
not the way that it works it's silly and
impotent to just complain and say well
what if what if the shoe was on the
other foot what if the rolls were
reversed that's not the way it is we are
living in a particular circumstance
in our classrooms in our politics and we
need to deal with that and this teacher
teaching students is not going to be
good for white kids not going to be good
for black kids it's not going to be good
for any kind of kids because this
teacher is teaching
things that are false and then also a
real
sort of vitriol a real sort of
resentment that is not conducive to
education fire the teacher simple as
that it's not only radical racial stuff
in the classroom
perhaps even more so it's this radical
sexual stuff another
i'm so grateful to tick-tock if it is
the case that tick-tock is not merely
chinese propaganda designed to weaken
the west from within and make us all
think our culture is crazy
if tick-tock is real and these are real
people out there going on to social
media and expressing their real views
then tick tock is doing a wonderful
service i love i want i think the
government should subsidize tick tock
because it's showing us for the first
time perhaps in many many years what's
actually going on in the classroom so
what one teacher is doing
is he's saying we are going to have a
transgender
closet in our classroom and so what's
going to happen is students are going to
come to school and then we're going to
convince little boys that they're little
girls and little girls that they're
little boys and then they're going to
come out and they're going to be
inducted into our creepy sexual cult and
we're not going to tell their parents
the goal of the transition closet is for
our students to be able to wear the
clothes that their parents approve of
come to school and then swap out into
the clothes that fit who they truly are
and i use the idea that this is like
superman changing in a phone booth but
that idea actually goes a lot further
than that because superman isn't
clark kent clark kent is actually the
disguise and when clark kent goes into
the phone booth he transforms into
superman who's really just who he truly
is kal-el and so this gives our trans
students the opportunity to be the
superheroes that we know they are
what a creepy pervert i just
i don't know who else he
i'm not saying that he has bad
intentions necessarily but he's wrong
he's got a very
mistaken view of the world and you would
have to be a creepy pervert to try to
obsess over little kids
sexual desires that's you just would
have even if you don't know that you're
being a creepy pervert you are and you
shouldn't be in a classroom
you shouldn't be in a classroom because
it's weird and it's creepy and also on
the educational front the view that he
is giving of human nature
his anthropology is just not correct
he's saying that the body has nothing to
do with who you really are that if
you're a boy but you think on some level
that you're a girl
that's who you truly are that's why he
uses the superman clark kent
analogy
and he's saying it's who you it's who
you actually 100 are and your physical
appearance has nothing to do with it and
so we're going to teach kids that well
if you teach kids that view of human
nature what you're telling them is you
can't believe in christianity which says
that human beings are body and soul
together you can't believe in judaism
you can't believe in islam you can't you
can't you can't believe
what
very likely your parents have raised you
to believe
that's all false ignore your parents
ignore your biology ignore reality
ignore your god believe our creepy weird
sex cult
and thank you taxpayers for paying for
it and by the way parents if you have
any problem with it get bent
maybe the guy's a nice guy i don't know
probably he's not but let's say that he
is it doesn't matter the stakes are too
high here folks classrooms are crystal
balls you look at a classroom you're
looking at your culture in 20 years
do you want your culture to be one where
ordinary true views of human nature and
the the cultural and religious views
that built our entire civilization are
banned or kicked out in favor of
convincing your little johnny that he's
really little jane no
fire the teachers what are we going to
do
what are we going to do about it
all we can do all i can do from my
microphone right here at this table
is expose this stuff call it to your
attention
and
explain why it's so bad and what the
stakes are
then what some other parents can do is
go complain and that's good you got to
complain you got to go you got to bring
this to the attention of the
administrators of the teachers of the
school boards but they don't really care
then you can go and you bring it to the
legislators you can try to kick out the
leg but we've got to gain
more power than that right now the left
has a total lock on every single
institution
the rot runs so deep you've got to go in
not even just to the school boards but
into the classrooms you've got to become
teachers you've got to become
administrators you've got to enter that
teacher union you've got to grab that
power back or these creepy pervs are
going to destroy the next generation of
americans if they haven't done so
already
not good stuff not good stuff we've got
to be able to do things for ourselves
like for instance when you want to order
auto parts
when i want to order auto parts i go to
rockauto.com time is money
money is money too and right now time
and money are in short supply because
we've got inflation going through the
roof and everybody's just trying to
scrape and make ends meet so what i
would recommend is you don't waste time
driving to the physical brick and mortar
auto parts store then getting out of the
car and then waiting in a line and then
you get up to the guy and the guy
peppers you with a thousand questions
about the auto parts and then you say i
don't know i don't know what make a
model and this and that then he goes in
the back
they do not have the part because
there's too many parts to stock these
days then he comes back he says yeah
we'll order it'll be in in two weeks you
go you drive home you go home or
whatever then you drive back it's a
waste of time go to rockauto.com okay
rockauto.com
family business it's been serving auto
parts customers online for 20 years
super easy to navigate even i can do it
that's how simple the catalog is same
prices for pros and do-it-yourselfers no
gimmicks always reliably low prices go
to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts that you need for your car or
truck and then most importantly write
knolls in their how did you hear about
us box so they know that we sent you the
teacher unions
are one of the
most effective ways that these radical
leftists can hold on to power in
education which means the way that they
can reshape the entire generation which
means the way that they can reshape the
whole country the teacher unions and
these are some of the most dishonest
corrupt people in the country who run
these teacher unions give a great
example
jesse aguilar
jesse aguilar is a board member
of the california teacher union one of
the worst in the country
jesse aguilar
he is insistent that students wear masks
in school
the california teacher union is
insistent that students wear masks in
school it's only it's responsible it's
for the public health it's looking out
for the greater good
come on folks don't be so selfish put
hey come on little kids put on those
masks
and then jesse aguilar just went to the
super bowl
and he went to the super bowl in l.a
right
and jesse aguilar didn't wear a mask
because none of these people really
believe that the masks do much of
anything at all and even if they do
they realize that it doesn't matter if
they wear one if everyone else is
wearing one then they don't need to wear
one
and you know it's
look
it's fun if you go to the super bowl
probably you're a powerful wealthy elite
sort of person so they're all clean
right it's you're not really worried
about their nice elite germs they don't
really have any germs it's just the
filthy dirty poor people it's just the
little it's the little kids
and the people who have just as much
power as little kids which is nothing
you know the kind of the waiters ugh you
know and the drivers yuck
oh and all the other those filthy little
people they need to wear their masks
but we powerful union bosses we don't
need to wear armor we celebrities
we elected politicians we we don't need
to wear our masks because we're clean
and we're nice people and now make sure
you put your mask on while you get me my
next glass of champagne
and what are you going to do about it
nothing
the reason that the kids are the last
group that has to wear the masks even
though the kids are the least likely
people to go to the hospital or die or
spread kovid
kovid 19.
why is it that the group that is safest
from kovid is the last one that has to
wear the masks because they have the
least power
the whole thing is about power politics
and the kids are a perfect example
because kids by definition don't have
any power
and you can see this
up through every other segment of
society
the working classes political
conservatives for that matter who don't
have any institutional power in this
country which is why whenever we say
true things about covet or any other
question we get censored
and we don't there's nothing we can do
about it donald trump the sitting
president of the united states didn't
have the institutional power not to get
booted out of the public square so
little kids obviously
what are they going to do they maybe
they'll complain but who cares you'll
just tune them out
we're all we're all in the position of
those kids right now
and we are all being run rough shot over
specifically by these left-wing teachers
but
but they're the rest of their cohort as
well
dc is finally
listening to some of their voters
they have to the democrats know that
they are headed for a
an avalanche of republican votes this
november so they're desperately trying
to change course so dc
which instituted a draconian vaccine
mandate and mask mandate just a month or
so ago where you can you can't even go
into a restaurant without someone
checking your papers you have to have 75
masks on your face you got to work
basically you have to wear a full burka
if you want to go get a beer in
washington dc well now
they're lifting the indoor mask mandate
they just they previously announced they
were gonna lift the vaccine mandate now
they're gonna lift
the indoor mass mandate
they're gonna lift the indoor mask
mandate
in restaurants
and bars
sports and entertainment venues
and supermarkets and pharmacies and
retail businesses and private offices
and government offices and houses of
worship and strip clubs and strip clubs
but there's one place they're going to
keep the mask mandate you know where it
is
schools
the little kids
with the lowest risk of covid
catching it or spreading it
they have to mask up
but some filthy degenerate probably
politician if i probably member of
congress walking into some dirty rotten
hunter biden strip club in washington dc
doing
heaven knows what
with people who are probably not the
most hygienic and sanitary people in the
world
they don't need to wear the mask that'll
be clean that'll be fine but little kids
trying to learn their abcs their reading
writing and their arithmetic
they need to mask up
what are you going to do about it
what do you get the kids are going to
complain and the teachers are going to
say okay you're a kid shut up who cares
but the strip clubs well there you're
going to get politicians complaining
there you're going to get the
president's son complaining and when the
listen when the president's son come
when hunter complains when the big guy
complains when all those
dirty rotten degenerates who want to go
to the strip clubs complain well then
people listen why because they have
more power
it's a bet yet i wish that we lived in a
time where politics was a little more
reasonable
where it was a little bit more logical
open to reason a little bit more civil
politics can always be a bit of a blood
sport but there are times when it's more
civilized than at other times there are
times when we we sort out our problems
through reason debate there are times
when we sort out our problems by
whipping and caning each other on the
steps of the capital and i think we're a
little closer to the latter right now
than the former
but you've got to accept reality we are
right now we are in power politics time
that's what the left has told us that
leftist said politics is not about
reason it's not about logic
all of those things are just constructs
of bigotry and white supremacy and all
sorts of uh evil and so it's not that's
not what politics is just about interest
groups and enforcing through tyranny of
will our desires on the rest of the
country that's what we're so okay if
that's the way politics is
and the left controls every single
institution then we've got to go in and
take back those institutions we've got
to build parallel institutions we've got
to go in and take back their
institutions and the ones we can't take
back we've got to defund
and
politically speaking legislatively
speaking
raise them knock them to the ground and
plow the earth with salt where they once
stood
okay that's what we that's what we
should do in silicon valley or in some
of the elite schools and the teacher
union buildings is metaphorically
figuratively through legislation perhaps
get rid of their buildings and salt the
earth where they stood because as long
as they're holding on to power we can
whine and complain until we're blue in
the face it's not going to do anything
strip clubs
get to take their masks off but the
little kids don't speaking of stripping
i've got some
i've got some
disturbing news
if you're driving pull over if you're
standing up you're probably going to
want to sit down
the singer lizzo
known for very publicly and very
emphatically being corpulent
and proud of
her corpulence
lizzo wants to
strip
for playboy
[Music]
i'm speechless
i she was asked by tmz about playboy she
said i love playboy i want to strip for
playboy and i don't i'm really
torn here i think a lot of conservatives
are in a tough spot because it's very
rude to say anything mean certainly
about a woman's appearance but really
about anybody's appearance and i don't
want to do that
i don't i don't i want to be polite i
want to be nice i i no one but the
culture is kind of forcing us to now
because the
leftist culture is dead set on
destroying all traditional standards
standards of truth standards of beauty
standards of virtue and goodness and
they're
they're installing a kind of
anti-standard in its place
right we're told not only
are you not allowed to say that men are
not women but you have to say that
certain men are women
not only are you not allowed to say that
uh certain art let's say the sistine
chapel is more beautiful than other art
say the the urinal by the modern artist
in those stupid modern art museums not
only are you not allowed to say that you
have to say that the modern art is
beautiful
you ha and so we have to all the
billboards now all of the advertising
used to have smoke and hot women
advertising all of the clothing and new
products now it's actively trying to
model things on
not the most beautiful stuff
nobody wants lizzo to
model in playboy one because you know
it's probably not
the most edifying ennobling thing in the
world it probably wouldn't be great for
lizzo pro and but people
people don't want to see that and it's
not
that's not bigoted not to want to see
lizzo naked it's not it's not it doesn't
make you a bad person that you don't
fight if you don't find lizzo attractive
or physically attractive okay there is
this
there's this amazing
misunderstanding of what really matters
in life going on here because
on the one hand you've got
the previously in our society maybe 20
30 years ago you had an obsession with
perfecting the body airbrushing all
these sorts of eating disorders all
these ways to to plastic surgery to make
yourself look perfect because you have
to perfect the body now we've moved in
completely the opposite direction people
want to distort their bodies through
mutilations through a very sort of
insane piercings and tattooing and and
uh eating disorders in the other
direction so we're we're focused on
basically the same thing two sides of
the same point we've got to perfect the
body in all ways
when was the last time we talked about
perfecting the soul when was the last
time we talked about ennobling ourselves
and practicing virtue and that that's
completely gone
from the conversation we're stuck in
this crazy materialist trap
you know one way to get out of these
materialist traps is to tune into people
who are
trying to turn the culture in a
different direction and that would i
hate you know listen i don't want to
toot our own horn but that's what we're
trying to do here at the daily wire
we're not even just commenting on
culture
we are making culture ourselves
we've just released our first original
movie shut in
the movie currently has a 100 critic
score
and a 97 audience score on rotten
tomatoes
these are shocking numbers i did look i
i i just thought the critics were going
to kill us and i thought you know i
thought the audience our audience would
love it but then the left would go in
and bring the numbers down they can't do
it though because the movie is too good
so if you missed it head on over to
dailywire.com subscribe right now you
can subscribe to the daily wire to get
shut in
to get our next movie hyperions to get
our next movie with gina carano terror
on the prairie to get all of our shows
to get a whole lot of other content
we're going to keep that content coming
we're going to try to change the culture
also
you know the best way to fight the
insidious attack on america right now is
to expose the source from within we've
got one of daily wire's newest projects
coming up the enemy within our new
series featuring acclaimed journalist
and expert in national threats lee smith
lee is going to uncover a political coup
orchestrated by america's ruling class
to generate their own wealth and power
at the expense of the american people's
safety and freedom check out the trailer
what if everything we think we know
about our leaders
our society and our relations with the
rest of the world is wrong
america is facing two major challenges
one is the chinese communist party
however the most significant threat
comes from within as you're trying to
obscure responsibility for four million
people dying around the world senator
paul you do not know what you are
talking about
we've already seen evidence of how the
elites want to run the united states
they're modeling themselves after
chinese autocracy for over a decade the
people's republic of china
has stood publicly accused of acts of
cruelty
and wickedness
that matched the cruelty and wickedness
of many evil torturers and executioners
dianne feinstein
had a chinese spy as her driver for 20
years we're not talking about
one person infiltrating senior levels at
the cia or the white house we're talking
about an entire elite class
throughout the political corporate
academic cultural and media
establishment my name is lee smith i've
been a journalist for more than 30 years
this is the most astonishing espionage
and infiltration operation in history
what you're going to see in this series
will shock you
this
is the enemy within
the enemy within is going to start
streaming february 18th only at the
daily wire so if you're not a member
head on over right now dailywire.com
subscribe join today we'll be right back
with a lot more
speaking of playboy
there are more
horrifying report reports out about hugh
hefner so we covered one a few weeks ago
on the show one of hugh hefner's more
recent girlfriends said that he's
actually an old creep
with shocking right this is breaking
news
guy who lives in bathrobe with lots of
women and
brags about sleeping with them all the
time might be sort of a creep uh well
there's there's a new series that's
coming out and uh one of hefner's older
girlfriends from the 70s tells even more
disgusting stories so hefner's former
girlfriend
says that
the founder of playboy was a monster who
spoke to her about getting sexual
pleasure from watching snuff films
that's films where people get killed
and even
got got frisky with one of her dogs
like an actual dog like an animal
she said quote he was like a vampire he
was sucking the life out of me really he
was a monster the things he was turned
on by nothing was enough uh nothing
he would tell the public even good girls
enjoy sex healthy sex and there was
nothing healthy about the sex with
hefner because he took it too far the
reason i mention this is one also to
discourage lizzo from
stripping for playboy but two
to remind people something that it it
seems obvious
until
you get the temptation
and the thing is you can't get around
the moral order
you can't get around it
you think you can so much of modern
leftism modern political ideologies are
just about overcoming the moral order
through your own will just overcoming
ideas of good and bad right which which
uh
radicals on the left and the right have
called a slave morality bourgeois
morality you got to overcome all of that
and then just do whatever you want all
the time and then life's going to be
really great and it's not really great
you can't overcome it this is why you
see celebrities ruin their lives you
think man if i were a celebrity if i
were rich and famous man i'd have the
greatest life you know all if i just had
some more money and a little more fame
and power
boy i'd live the greatest life ever and
then what happens to statistically 100
percent of celebrities they get drug
addictions their marriages fall apart
their kids hate them and they die early
that's what happens to almost all of
them why they have every advantage they
have all they have all the good things
that all the people want
because they take it all to excess
because they think that they can
overcome the moral order the rules don't
apply to them the rules don't apply to
the elites
in the teacher unions or in the
government or in the media the rule
why why do we have to follow the rules
we're special
it's hypocrisy of course
but it's it's a hideous double standard
of course but it's also destructive for
them
because when we're talking about good
rules we're talking about the actual
moral rules of the universe they are
there for your benefit they will if you
follow them or try to follow them you
will that will lead to human flourishing
and if you don't then you're going to
end up a dirty rotten filthy
uh
despised degenerate like like hugh
hefner don't do that you don't want to
do that speaking of
so this is sort of sexual degenerates
sort of this theme of the show prince
andrew
the i'm sorry former the artist formerly
known as prince andrew who got fired
from the royal family by his own mother
because he was such a sex fiend prince
andrew has just settled his case with
one of jeffrey epstein's
former
call girls so
uh prince andrew
they've settled this out of court
he quote intends to make a substantial
donation to ms jeffrey's charity in
support of victims rights and this is
the statement put out by andrew's
lawyers prince andrew has never intended
to malign ms jewfrey's character and he
accepts that she has suffered both as an
established victim of abuse and as a
result of unfair public attacks it is
known that jeffrey epstein trafficked
countless young girls over many years
prince andrew regrets his association
with epstein and commends the bravery of
ms jewfrey and other survivors in
standing up for themselves and others
previously he said i don't know this
woman i have nothing to do with her i
didn't do it no i never did anything bad
with jeffrey no the only reason i kept
hanging out with him after he got
convicted for his kid sex stuff is
because i was too good a friend i'm just
too loyal you know and like in a job
interview what's your greatest weakness
i work too hard i care too much that was
andrew's first claim and then it was
undeniable he's got photos with this
chick and then so finally he he says
okay or never mind uh his mother fires
him from the royal family he loses his
titles he loses all of the perks of
being a royal and now he's got to settle
this claim out of court notice
notice though he never accepts
responsibility
so what happens here i imagine he
offered this woman a bazillion dollars
he offered her some
absolutely jaw-dropping some of money
she said okay fine it's sort of like
you're admitting guilt here and i'll
take the money and okay it'll go toward
her charity
and prince andrew never has to actually
admit
guilt here which is too bad but
regardless it looks really bad it's
really undignified
okay and it's just it's
it's a cautionary tale for everybody
prince andrew born with as much
privilege as could be given the greatest
education you could possibly be given
this guy destroys his life and he's the
laughing stock of the world because he
gave into his appetites and temptations
don't be that guy don't get fired by
your mom that's really embarrassing okay
and the only really really sad thing
about this the way the epstein case is
resolving with these out of court
settlements and and the sealing up of
the black book during the gillane
maxwell case is i want to know who else
i want to know who else and i want to
know who else for sure and i want
details and i want these people
who flew on jeffrey epstein's plane
who look i'm sure there were people who
flew on his plane and knew jeffrey
epstein who were completely innocent
really the reason for that is jeffrey
epstein was throwing money around he was
donating to a lot of very big charities
and foundations and so a lot of people
met him in high society who probably had
nothing to do with the girls
but a lot of them did have something to
do with the girls and i want to find out
who they are and i want the details but
they're probably just going to get away
with it
they're probably just going to get away
with it could because the ruling elite
have power
and we're on to them
right we know what they're up to
they know that we know
what they're up to
and we know that they know that we know
what they're up to
but it doesn't matter
because they still have
the power
we're going to need to do we're going to
need to do a lot more than just win some
elections or make some documentaries
or post some things on social media we
have to do a lot more to get actual
political power back and then have the
confidence to wield that political power
we're gonna we're going to now speaking
of
epidemics
it's a little bit of a hard transition
but speaking of just filth pervading our
culture omicron amicron
is uh that's the latest one you know
that's spreading around and we're
supposed to shut down the world for that
well they said okay we're gonna shut
down the world until we get a vaccine
for omicron to stop that surge well
they're trying to get a vaccine for
omicron except the early tests from the
new omicron vaccine show that they the
vaccines don't do anything more than the
vaccines that already exist
which isn't very much when it comes to
omicron
according to david montefiore the
director of the lab for aids vaccine
research and development at duke's
medical center who's been researching
now covid vaccines he says what we're
seeing come out of these pre-clinical
studies in animal models is that a boost
with a variant vaccine doesn't really do
any better than a boost with the current
vaccine
but of course
of course if you were betting
this time they're going to be right
this time they've been wrong about every
other aspect of of the virus from
the origin of the virus to the
mitigation measures for the virus to the
time label table for vaccines to the
efficacy of the vaccines to the this to
that to the every single thing but now
they'll be right
if you believe that i got a bridge in
brooklyn to sell you it doesn't matter
by the way so there was never going to
be a great there is not a great vaccine
there is not a vaccine that does all the
things they said the vaccine would do
which includes stopping infection and
transmission we don't have that there
was never a great perfect vaccine there
was never going to be a great vaccine
for omicron and by the way it wouldn't
matter if there were because there's
just going to be another variant they're
already talking about the next variant
they're they're making a vaccine for the
variant that's about to go away and
there's going to be a new variant
because it's a virus and that's what
happens
it's just going to go on and on and on
and
those of us who are still i mean i i
suspect most people listening to this
show don't believe the fouchies of the
world anymore if they ever did
but for the vast majority of people
it's their charlie brown
with and with lucy in the football they
say oh but this time i'm going to let
you kick a charlie brown okay i can't
wait to get the omicron vaccine then
then then we can go back to normal i'll
just wear 10 more masks for 10 more days
and then oh and then what happens she
pulls the football away
it's maybe time to change strategy a
little bit here
okay because if we keep
playing by the same old playbook we're
gonna end up in exactly the same
place
they just keep getting away with it
hillary clinton i can't it's amazing
that we're talking about all of these
other things when
maybe the most egregious political
scandal in our nation's history just
took place just was proven
and the media are blacking it out what's
that the scandal that just took place is
that hillary clinton associates were
spying on donald trump as he said as the
media and the establishment denied
spying on donald trump when he was a
candidate
in his home where he was running his
campaign
and as president
they were spying on the sitting
president of the united states and
trying to frame him for colluding with
the russians which is something the
democrats themselves had been doing for
100 years
and hillary clinton was behind almost
all of it
and no one's talking about it there was
one woman who confronted hillary as
hillary was walking into her apartment
building
she was an apartment building or her
house i can't quite tell she was walking
wherever she was going i'm sure the
clintons had plenty of property she was
walking in and and the woman said
hillary what you got caught spying you
got caught spying what does hillary do
she laughs
hilary laura collins daily mail did you
pay to spy on the trump campaign what
are you going to comment on the spying
allegations hillary
did you pay for having spied on
hillary are you going to comment on this
major scandal that you are not only
involved in but behind that was just
shown in a doj report from john durham
hi bye bye see you and she waves it off
good on this woman for confronting
hillary
why isn't every journalist in america
outside hillary clinton's door right now
how it why is hillary clinton even
allowed to walk to her front door there
aren't so many news crews and and
cameras and vans parked out front trying
to get comment on
very possibly the most egregious
political scandal in our country's
history
because they're all on the same team
they're all in on it
cnn and nbc and abc and the new york
times and washington
they don't care
they're not
they're not they're not reporters
they're not investigative journalists
they're just on the team and there's one
set of rules for the team
and there's another set of rules for the
rest of us
and they've got the institutional power
and we don't so the best we can muster
is some lady showing up with a cell
phone saying hillary give me an answer
they laugh at us they laugh at hillary
clinton is laughing at that woman and
laughing at us
justin trudeau
up in canada justin castro up in canada
is laughing at us there was a clip it
just resurfaced of justin trudeau was
asked which country he most admires in
the world no it's not cuba that would
have been funny if he said cuba no it's
not cuba the answer is somehow even
worse do you do you know which country
justin trudeau most admires
china
even with sun tv watching for any slip
he was asked which country he most
admired and referred to china there's a
level of of uh admiration i actually
have for china
um
because their
basic dictatorship is allowing them
uh to actually turn their economy around
on a dime and say we need to go green as
fast as we need to start you know
investing in solar i mean there is a
flexibility that i know stephen harper
must dream about of having a
dictatorship that he could do everything
he wanted
that i find quite interesting
when people tell you who they are
you should believe them
justin trudeau is telling you exactly
what he thinks he's not making a joke
he's he's telling the truth
this is not this shouldn't be a surprise
to anybody who's been paying attention
to what the left has been doing in our
country and in our civilization for a
long time now
they want to move away from democratic
accountability they want to move away
from our constitutional order they want
to move away from our traditions in
america and they want to move toward a
centralized technocratic hierarchy that
doesn't need to answer to the people
because the people are filthy dirty
rotten idiots according to the left and
only the genius elite guru expert dr
faucis know how to run our country never
mind that fauci's gotten pretty much
every major issue wrong for the last 40
years but he's got really impressive
credentials and he talks in a really a
very a tight but but still folksy and
charming way and so we've got to just
listen to him and whatever and look you
might not like it but trust me he's
right in the end what do you want the
people running your country
of course china's the model
what is china it's communist and the
left has had a love affair with
communism for a very long time but even
more than that
it's technocratic it's just run by the
experts the left openly loves that and
it's atheist and the left openly loves
that and the left hates christianity and
the left hates
traditional religious views and they've
been trying to overcome them for well
over a century now and they've largely
succeeded at least in the public square
so of course they love china
and of course they don't want to call
out china for unleashing this pandemic
on the world
and frankly they probably think they
stand to benefit from the pandemic they
do that's not a conspiracy theory you
might have heard especially if you're
reading left-wing
mainstream sources that there is a
conspiracy theory called the great reset
that the global elites
the can you believe these rube
conservatives they think that global
elites
love kovid because it's giving them an
opportunity to have a great reset of the
world what a crazy conspiracy theory
that you can read about in those exact
words on the world economic forum
website
the world economic forum
is
is an organization was founded some
years ago it's been it's been around for
a long time now to bring together the
corporate and political and media elites
from all around the world to figure out
how to transform our backwards
traditional nation-states national order
into a more globalized cosmopolitan
secular multicultural which is really
monocultural because you're erasing all
the actual cultural differences between
different countries just to turn it into
this wonderful
technocratic
future the world economic forum
on one of their web pages titled the
great reset says
the pandemic
represents a rare but narrow window of
opportunity to reflect
reimagine
and reset our world
this according to professor klaus schwab
the founder and executive chairman of
the world
economic forum they say you know you can
follow
follow insights
on how we can recover from coven 19 to
build a healthier
more equitable
and more prosperous future
what is the world economic forum i don't
know it's just really powerful people
flexing their power
where is the world economic forum in the
constitution no nowhere where where's
the world economic forum in our system
of government no it's not it's not
written down but it exerts a lot of
influence certainly the people who show
up to it have a lot of influence
they're the leaders of the world not
only in politics but in culture in
private business and really sort of
public business the distinction is a
little blurry in education in all over
they're focused on education too the
world economic forum just released a
video on how important it is to defend
critical race theory
what is critical race theory and why is
it so controversial they write
supporters of crt say it's a way to
understand and tackle racial inequality
however opponents crt say crt does the
opposite so what is crt
the theory was first developed by u.s
legal scholars in the 1980s
it argues that the laws rules and
regulations that govern society today
have been shaped by the historical
subordination of people of color
and that this is a driving force beyond
racial inequality today we got the nice
music
take the us criminal justice system for
example while everyone is seen as equal
under the law
[Music]
black americans are imprisoned at five
times the rate of white americans that's
what they're they say this disparity is
a legacy of america's racist past
notice they don't they don't talk about
they don't talk about like crime rates
they just talk about imprisonment rates
supporters of crt say that the opponents
miss the point they say a system doesn't
need racists working within it to
produce racially imbalanced outcomes and
so it's really just built into the
system and it's really awful so what
what the world economic forum is trying
to do is just what the libs always try
to do which is present their extremely
radical views and their radical agenda
to completely reset the world
as just a kind of moderate idea look
we're taking all sides we're really
inclusive
we're really open-minded we're going to
take
and we're going to listen to the crt
supporters and we're going to listen to
the crt opponents and it just so happens
that the crt opponents are awful
disgusting vile bigots who should never
be heard ever again and the crt
supporters are and that's what we're
going to do
and we have all the business leaders and
we've got all the political leaders
and all the media leaders
and all the elites
from every segment of society all over
the even semi-civilized world
and we're just gonna kind of do it and
because we're a non-governmental
organization
and because we're working through lots
of other ngos
you're not even going to really have
much say in it because it's not it's not
going to be the congress that's passing
this stuff it's going to be the
corporations that show up to i don't
mean even just a single at the world
economic forum it's going to be
the people who show up to this and
similar sort of events and organizations
they're going to push it through their
businesses they're going to push it
through their corporate trainings
they're going to push it through the
classrooms they're going to push it
through and you're not going to say
nothing about it it's a reset you want
to talk about a reset
van jones van jones is a cnn
analyst he's as far as left-wing
analysts go he's one of the more honest
ones he admitted early on though it was
on a hidden camera that the russia stuff
with donald trump was just completely
bogus he said it was a nothing burger
and then but then he had to walk it back
because tv cameras showed up so van
jones
is resetting not just his politics but
his personal life he says after the
covet lockdown i got clear that i wanted
another kid i discovered that my friend
noemi also wanted a baby
so we decided to join forces and become
conscious co-parents
it's a concept that i hope more people
will explore and consider this month we
welcome to earth a baby girl whom we
will raise as co-parenting partners this
is a special time for our families i
feel grateful joyful and blessed as we
create a safe and loving environment for
this blessed young soul i respectfully
ask for your privacy thank you for all
the love and support so van jones
already has two kids with his ex-wife
and uh they were married in 20 2005 they
divorced uh four years ago
and so he says well we'll continue
raising our kids together running our
businesses together and supporting each
other's growth
this is what van johnson's ex said in a
joint statement there's no b for drama
just evolution it's no it's no drama
okay yeah he's gonna he had kids
and with his wife and then the family
split up and he abandoned his family and
then he's going to co-pair he's going to
consciously co-parent with his friend
because he he wants another kid
he wanted to get another kid and it's
cool and there's no drama it's just what
he wants and it's fine it's evolution
there's no drama there i bet there's
drama for the kids
okay i don't want to get involved in
someone's personal life but he's making
it public and he's a public figure
this is a really pressing public
political question
this is extremely selfish
and wrong don't this actually ties in to
the most important story today we don't
have a ton of time to get into it but i
have to bring up the most important
story is kanye kanye kanye right now is
in the process potentially this divorce
with kim kardashian they've got these
kids and he's saying i want to get back
with my family i want my family to come
back to me please don't break up our
family and kim kardashian is dating that
derelict from saturday night live and so
kanye is making fun of the guy he keeps
calling him skeet and he says for
everyone married hold your spouse close
make sure they know how much you love
and appreciate them because there's a
skeet lurking in every dirty ass alley
waiting to help destroy your family and
walk around in calvin kleins around your
children i wish my wife was with me and
our children sitting at the 50-yard line
at the super bowl i in in the battle
here between team kanye and team
team kim and team skeet i guess he has
his own team i am 100 team kanye he's
right
it's an actual important question i know
most people don't care about celebrity
drama and tiffs it's an important
question because what kanye's
articulating is the traditional view
that marriage is a covenant it's a
compact you don't get to just break it
up willy-nilly over nothing family
matters family is the basic building
block of society and kim kardashian is
representing the modern view of hey she
just put this in vogue magazine i'm in
my 40s i'm just going to make all the
choices that i want to make and i don't
really care what my kids want i don't
care what my husband wants i don't care
what anyone else wants it's just me me
me me and if i want to date skeet i'm
going to date skeet that's the wrong
view it is going to destroy our culture
it already has largely destroyed our
culture stand with yeezy okay i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
john bickley here daily wire editor in
chief wake up every morning with our
show morning wire where we bring you all
the news that you need to know in 15
minutes or less
join me and my co-host georgia hal for
daily coverage of all the biggest
stories on morning wire